[Music]
the term mutation brings countless
fantasies to our mind right from the
ability to fly high in the sky to that
of diving deep into the oceans we all
love to have such fantastic abilities
but these are all fictitious such
fantasies don't exist so can we say that
mutation also doesn't exist
hold on that's not true mutation does
exist but mutation doesn't lead to such
drastic changes in us humans we can't
have mutations that give us
extraordinary powers rather most
mutations give rise chicken son they
result in undesirable changes from time
to time in these upcoming videos we
shall majorly talk about mutation what
causes them and that types in general
let's begin with the definition first
mutation in simple words is defined as
sudden and abrupt changes to the genetic
material of organisms now let's break
this down to understand it better sudden
and abrupt changes means a few changes
that occur suddenly and are mostly
unexpected these changes are usually
random and disruptive to the normal
functioning of the cell and where do
these changes occur they occur in the
genetic material of the organism that
means in the DNA and as a result either
the gene or the complete chromosome gets
affected so mutations are spontaneous
changes that affect the DNA or the genes
or sometimes the complete chromosomes
now since these are the areas that get
altered mutations are categorized on the
basis of them the two major types of
mutation are genetic mutation and
chromosomal mutation let us see these
types let's consider this small section
of the DNA let's say that this part
changes into another another possibility
is that either this base gets deleted or
an extra gets inserted in either case
the outcome is that the sequence of the
gene will change
technically the reading frame will
change the ribosome assembly including
the tRNA reads the genetic code in
triplets these triplets are called
codons now if there's any change in a
single nucleotide then the entire codon
will change does the reading frame will
change and what will this result to
that's right the author gene will give
rise to a different protein than the
usual one and there are chances that
this defective protein turns out to be a
harmful one so any change in the DNA or
in the genes can't cause a shift in the
reading frame as a result an altered
protein is produced this was the first
type now let's zoom out of the DNA
structure what do we see yes we see a
typical chromosomal structure now tell
me what will happen if there are any
alterations in its structure and what if
the total number of chromosomes get
altered let's find the answer in the
next part this is a representative
karyotype of a human by now we know what
a karyotype is can you try to give me
some conclusions of it you may say that
it looks perfectly normal but let me
spot a flaw for you do you notice this
set this is the 21st chromosome set
instead of having a normal pair of
chromosomes here we find a triplet now
you may say that it may be good for the
individual as it has an extra chromosome
but that's not the case any change in
the number of chromosomes creates a lot
of defects in the normal functioning of
the body
on this note let's understand
chromosomal mutations as the name says
chromosomal mutation means the mutation
of chromosomes and how exactly does it
get mutated it can happen in two ways
one way is where the structure of the
chromosomes gets disrupted the other is
where the number of chromosomes are
different than the usual in the organism
let's have a look at each type this is
the structure of a typical chromosome
now imagine this small part gets
physically removed this would result the
chromosome and getting smaller as its
segment is lost this also means that if
the segment had some important genes
then they will also get lost which can
result in severe abnormalities such type
of a mutation is called deletion this is
where the part of the chromosome gets
deleted now imagine this part of the
chromosome gets duplicated as a result
the chromosomes length increases
needless to say this will also result in
some of the other abnormality in the
individual this type of mutation is
called duplication now comes the next
type these are two different gene
segments imagine they get flipped does
the chromosome will appear like this
this is called inversion do you think
this type of mutation is harmful it may
or may not be harmful depending on which
genes get flipped now let's take one
more chromosome imagine a part of this
chromosome gets removed and gets
inserted in this chromosome what will be
the result that's correct
both the chromosomes will change
drastically this type of mutation is
called as insertion and now comes the
last type instead of a segment getting
inserted to another chromosome let's
imagine a situation where a segment from
each chromosome gets indirect stage
so this segment will get into this
chromosome and vice versa
this kind of mutation also results in
abnormalities as both the chromosomes
get altered completely any idea what the
Stipe will be named as well this type of
mutation is called translocation all
these mutations resulting in the
disruption of normal chromosomal
structures are broadly capped under a
single heading they are categorized as
chromosomal aberrations now this was
about the mutations that involve changes
in the structure of the chromosomes what
about the mutations that involve a
change in the number of chromosomes
let's understand that in the next part
this is a normal chromosome while this
is a disrupted one when the structure of
a chromosome gets altered
it's called chromosomal aberration we
have seen this now let's move on to the
second type
it's the mutation that involves a change
in the number of chromosomes it's called
as a new ploidy in literal terms a new
ploidy means the presence of an abnormal
number of chromosomes in a cell so the
carrier type of a person with trisomy 21
is an example of a new chloe the
presence of one additional chromosome in
the 21st set gives rise to a total of 47
chromosomes in a person so instead of a
normal 46 chromosomes this person has an
additional chromosome to be precise an
additional autosome this case of a new
ploidy
is called trisomy 21 this is because
there are three chromosomes instead of
two in the 21st set the problem of
trisomy 21 leads to a condition called
Down syndrome we will get into the
details of these disorders in our higher
grades but for now let's focus on
understanding the chromosomal mutations
this anu ploidy involved an autosome now
tell me what if the number of sex
chromosome alters so instead of XY what
if an individual has X X Y is that even
possible in the first place well yes
there can be individuals with an
additional X chromosome this condition
is called Klinefelter syndrome such
individuals exhibit both masculine as
well as feminine characteristics
now in the case of females imagine that
instead of addition there is a deletion
of an X chromosome this would mean X oh
so this individual will have only one X
chromosome this condition is called
Turner syndrome there are a few
developmental abnormalities in such
scenarios these individuals have a total
of 45 chromosomes only these were a few
examples of a new ploidy that involves
autosomes and sex chromosomes now before
we conclude tell me one thing what
causes these mutations
how can DNA or genes or entire
chromosomes get altered there are
several factors named mutagens which
lead to alterations
some of them include radiation chemicals
and even certain consumable items to
summarize we have two major types of
mutations one which involves alterations
in the DNA or the genes these mutations
result a shift in the reading frame
resulting in defective protein synthesis
alterations in the structure results in
chromosomal aberrations they can be
categorized as deletion duplication
inversion insertion and translocation
the other is where the number of
chromosomes are different than the usual
in the organism it's called a new ploidy
the changes can be in the autosomes as
well as the sex chromosomes here the
total number of chromosomes in a cell
are different from the usual this was
about mutations in general to find more
interesting videos do not forget to
subscribe to our channels
you